Amsterdam's quirkiest hotel isn't found
in the city center it's located at the
port in a crane
Edwin Korn man owns and operates the
crane hotel
it's his brainchild the crane was
destined to be scrapped
until corn and bought it for 1 euro and
overhauled it the red coloured parts are
new the gray ones are all original
Carlota Arnold is going to test out this
unusual hotel for us
first she crimes the steps to the
purpose-built elevator which will take
us straight to the top
it's a half a minute later
Carlotta reaches her room in the fir
Alda Crane hotel which boasts three
Suites
Carlotta can't believe how beautiful it
is this is the old machinery room the
crane driver it was sitting in that
little corner over there renovating the
old industrial crane cost around 3
million euros what was the intention of
building this hotel or designing the
scram as a hotel I wanted to realize
something weird
totally weird Hotel the best most
designed sweetest in inner in the crane
in 2015 the feraldo was nominated for
european hospitality awards in three
categories its three suites were
decorated by top designers but even the
sheet furnishings are no match for the
breathtaking view this hotel certainly
isn't for anyone who's afraid of heights
it's built so you can look all the way
down from everywhere remodeling the
crane took three years Carlotta's room
is located 45 metres above the ground
more man is this high cause it makes me
feel queasy naturally the great view
over Amsterdam and the designer decor
have their price it costs four hundred
and thirty five euros to spend the night
here
breakfast not included but there's an
upper floor to explore too
how nice
it's absurd you're in a crane but you
forget that fact entirely because the
hotel is so lovingly furniture so tell
us when darkness falls as scenery
changes and there's still a big surprise
in store because at the cranes highest
point 60 meters up in the air there's a
whirlpool as a - indescribable good
once only crane operators could enjoy
this heavenly site now Carlotta has
spent the whole night in the crane so
how was it you sleep wonderfully in this
crane apart from one thing
at night it's odd when the elevator goes
up and down you hear it and think
something's moving you sense that the
cranes moving a bit anyway but we're
still in the same place as before good
nor declined to live before her a night
in this crane hotel is an unforgettable
experience